>> Bret: PETER, THANK YOU.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW
IN COURT, RIGHT NOW TO
INVALIDATE THE LAW.
GO TELL A MOTHER OR FATHER, SON
OR DAUGHTER HAS CANCER AND THEY
CAN’T GET INSURANCE BECAUSE THEY
NO LONGER HAVE THE PROTECTION
AND THAT IS HYSTERICAL.
A SHAME.
>> HHS, WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LIVES.
>> LET’S BRING IN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SECRETARY
ALEX AZAR TO TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S HEALTH CARE POLICY.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU HEARD SENATOR SCHUMER
SPEAKER PELOSI JUST MOMENTS AGO
SHE PUT OUT A STATEMENT SAYING
THAT THE PRESIDENT’S EXECUTIVE
ORDER IS BOGUS.
IT IS NOT WORTH THE PAPER IT IS
SIGNED ON AND IT’S AN INSULT TO
EVERY FAMILY RELYING ON THIS.
PRE-EXISTING HEALTH CARE.
WOULD YOU TO THAT?
>> FIRST OFF, THE
PRESIDENT TODAY ANNOUNCED A BOLD
PLAN TO DELIVER BETTER CARE,
MORE CHOICE, LOWER COST FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS AND THE PRESIDENT AND
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER SAID IT’S
THE POLICY OF THE UNITED STATES
TO ENSURE PEOPLE WITH
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS WITH
PRODUCTION WHETHER UNDER
EXISTING LAW OR IF THERE IS ANY
REPLACEMENT OF HER PAST.
LET US BE CLEAR ABOUT THE
STATUS QUO, RIGHT NOW UNDER THE
GLORIFIED OBAMACARE THAT MANY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT PROTECTS
PEOPLE WITH PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, A FAMILY UP TO AGE
55 IN MISSOURI MAKING $70,000 A
YEAR WILL SPEND $30,000 A YEAR
ON PREMIUMS AND $12,000 IN
DEDUCTIBLES.
THAT IS NOT THE PROTECTION
AGAINST PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS
AND THAT’S NOT AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE, THAT DOESN’T SOLVE
THEIR PROBLEMS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO WORK
WITH CONGRESS TO SOLVE THEIR
PROBLEMS IN A REAL WAY.
>> WHEN YOU SAY WORK WITH
CONGRESS, A G.O.P. PLAN HAS BEEN
TOUGH TO REALLY PIN DOWN.
SINCE THE EFFORTS TO DISMANTLE
AND THROW AWAY, OBAMACARE FAILED
AND NOW IT’S IN THE COURTS,
THERE IS NOT BEEN ONE G.O.P.
PLAN, HAS THERE?
>> RIGHT NOW, GIVEN THAT THE
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE,
THERE IS LIMITED DEGREES OF
FREEDOM THAT WE CAN DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS REVOLUTIONIZED
HEALTH CARE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND DELIVERED MORE CARE AND MORE
CHOICE AND LOWER COST.
HE’S DONE MORE IN THREE AND A
HALF YEARS TO HELP ALL THE
AMERICANS HEALTH CARE THAN ANY
PRESIDENT IN MODERN HISTORY.
IT’S MORE THAN OBAMACARE,
OBAMACARE IS ABOUT 20-25000000
PEOPLE AND INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE
AND IT IS THE MEDICAID
EXPANSION.
HE IS BRINGING TRANSPARENCY
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND THE
OWNERSHIP OF THE OWN ELECTRONIC
RECORD AND HE’S CHANGING
HEALTH CARE AND A FUNDAMENTAL
WAY THAT BENEFITS EVERY AMERICAN
AND NOT JUST OBAMACARE.
>> Bret: AS EXPECTED, THE
PRESIDENT GETS THE SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE THROUGH THE SENATE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
THE JUSTICE SITS ON THE COURTS
AND RULES ON THE OBAMACARE CASE.
WHAT DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
TELL THE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
ARE CONCERNED THAT THEY WON’T
HAVE OBAMACARE ANYMORE AS THEY
HEAD INTO THE DANGERS OF COVID
AND FLU SEASON AND EVERYTHING
ELSE?
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID WHICH IS
FIRST AND FOREMOST HE’S GOING TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE WITH
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS ARE
PROTECTED AND HE WILL REPLACE
IT.
HE WILL WORK WITH CONGRESS AND
AS SUCH A THING HAPPENS,
CONGRESS AT THAT TIME, DELIVER
BETTER HEALTH CARE FOR PEOPLE.
OBAMAOBAMACARE DID NOT DELIVER F
THEM, WE NEED QUALITY
HEALTH CARE FOR PEOPLE, BETTER
CHOICE AND INSTEAD OF THE FALSE
PROMISES THAT OBAMACARE
BASICALLY FAILED TO DELIVER ON
OF KEEP YOUR DR. INSURANCE PLAN
AND ALL THOSE LIES THAT WE ARE
TOLD, ACTUALLY DELIVERABLE LOWER
COST, BETTER CARE, AND ONE OF
THE THINGS HE DID TODAY THE
PRESIDENT DID TODAY FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY, HE IS
ALLOWED AS OF TODAY THE PATHWAYS
FOR THE IMPORTATION OF LORD DRUG
COSTS AND NO PRESIDENT HAS DONE
THAT BEFORE.
EVERY DEMOCRAT HAS SAID WHEN
THEY’VE BEEN PRESIDENT I’M GOING
TO DO THAT AND THEY FAILED TO DO
IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID THAT TODAY.
OPENING PATHWAYS.
AND FOR INDIVIDUALS AND STATES
TO IMPORTS AND LOWER COST
INSULIN TO BE REIMPORTED INTO
UNITED STATES WHERE IT’S MADE.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU ONE
LAST QUESTION ABOUT THE VACCINE
AND THE PROCESS.
THE FDA, THE FDA, HAD SPEAKING
ABOUT THE PROCESS AND THE
PRESIDENT WING AND ABOUT HOW
FAST IT’S GOING TO TAKE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> SCIENCE WILL GUIDE HER
DECISIONS.
FDA WILL NOT PERMIT ANY PRESSURE
FROM ANYONE TO CHANGE THAT.
I WILL FIGHT FOR SCIENCE,
MR. CHAIRMAN, I WILL FIGHT FOR
THE INTEGRITY OF THE AGENCY AND
I WILL PUT THE INTERESTS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BEFORE ANYTHING
ELSE.
>> I DON’T SEE ANY REASON WHY IT
SHOULD BE DELAYED, IF THEY
DELAYED A FEW WEEKS, YOU KNOW,
IT’S A LOT OF LIVES YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> IF THE FDA SAYS WE HAVE TO
SLOW THIS DOWN, IS THE END
ADMINISTRATION OKAY WITH THAT?
>> IF SCIENCE AND DATA AND THE
LEGAL CONSTRUCTS A SLOW DOWN
THEN WE SLOW DOWN BUT HERE’S
WHAT WE ARE DOING FOR MAKING
HISTORIC PROGRESS WITH GREAT
SPEED THANKS TO OPERATION WERE
UP SPEED AND TAKING THE
FINANCIAL PROCESS FROM THE DRUG
COMPANIES.
AS A RESULT, WE HAVE FOUR
VACCINES IN PHASE THREE
CLINICAL TRIALS AND TO A PUBLIC
COMPANY CEO SPEISER AND WHAT
SAYING THAT WE COULD SEE THEM.
MILLION OF DOSES AS WE SPEAK SO
WE CAN HAVE 100 MILLION DOSES OF
FDA GOLD STANDARD BY THE END OF
THE YEAR.
IT WILL NOT COMPROMISE ON SAFETY
AND EFFICACY STANDARDS AND
THERE’S MANY CHECKS BUILT INTO
THE SYSTEM.
AN INDEPENDENT DATA AND SAFETY
MONITORING AND IF WE EVEN SEE
DATA ACCORDING TO THREE
SPECIFIED END POINTS, DRUG
COMPANY WILL THEN HAVE TO REVIEW
IT AND CONSIDER THE DATA
ACCORDING TO THEIR OWN ETHICAL
STANDARDS BEFORE EVEN SUMMONING
AN APPLICATION.
THE FDA WILL CALL THE BALLS AND
STRIKES BY CAREER OFFICIALS
ACCORDING TO THE SAFETY AND
EFFICACY CENTERS THAT THEY HAVE
RELEASED PUBLICLY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD BE
REASSURED THAT ANY VACCINE THAT
IS APPROVED BY THE FDA IS GOING
TO BE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
ACCORDING TO THE OFFICIALS AND
THE STANDARDS OF THE FOOD AND